you can't be afraid to fail fear is the
worst and I say it all the time and like
Teddy Alice talks about this and he
learned this from custado and it's like
you know it's a well-known expression
but the coward and the hero feel the
same exact emotion when confronted with
a situation it's just how do you act in
response to the fear the hero is like
okay I see you I know you're there
here's how I'm going to handle this the
coward is like I this run or or or
ignore so you can be afraid to fail it's
just what are the actions that you're
taking in the face of that you can be
fearful you can't be afraid cuz you will
fail like if you try to do epic
you're going to fail the fraking road to
success is littered with failures like
anyone who's who's who's been super
successful has had failures along the
way it's impossible to like do epic
and not have failures